how you want i normal french border
corona guys this is an emotion
situation we gryce extraordinary action
hospitals doctors and nurses not
medical equipment such as ventilator so
testing kids
does relations and save a life and then
i the point my blog about old to protect
themselves from contamination minutes
late of this equipment and this can brook
spencer and dutton swipe to day how you
excepted
to eliminate for while searching texas
for the import of medical devices and
equipment from countries there always the
european union
this is good for hospitals and for
charities  for shampoo
this is our country music to using the
pressure and prices of Merkel a
protective equipment and to make up and
more affordable to give you an example
in italy customs duty of 12 percent aan
de value added tax of 20 percent is
lavetan sam face muscle  protect a
garment bag import from countries light
shine a a decision will make them one
touch ieper proventil eaters the average
value added tax rate is it 20%
this is the temporary measure and it will
apply for at least the next four months
or longueur if necessary